[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
another one
surprise no
[Music]
not surprised at all
hell by this afternoon we'll probably
have news that there's another one
somewhere else
it continues
it won't stop
unless we stop it someone tweeted out
this morning i forget who it was
the only thing that stops a bad guy with
a gun is a politician who has a set of
nuts
we see this morning susan collins
says oh democrats and republicans
there's some common ground
apparently susan collins thinks that
guns have learned their lesson
learn their [ __ ]
lesson just like the rest of the people
that she capitulates to makes excuses
for
listen
susan collins
we don't care about your common ground
that's not what we're concerned about
it's not
we're not concerned about common ground
in the senate between republicans and
democrats
there's plenty of common ground out here
90 percent
you dumb [ __ ] 90 percent
a people are for a bill
that your caucus is blocking
you republicans
common ground my [ __ ] ass
a hospital
a hospital
a grocery store a church
an elementary school
a hospital
what next
restaurant now we've had those
movie theater ah we had those two
what next
where to next
common ground
oh well it's a good thing it's a good
thing bunch you senators
republicans have decided that there's
common ground somewhere and these guns
has learned their lesson
it really is not difficult
it's not
and it gets easier and easier every day
to see exactly
what is happening because there was a
question about this gun
what kind of gun is it is a shotgun is
it a rifle is it a handgun
what kind of gun is it
what kind of gun is it the media is
waiting the media's waiting politicians
are waiting
to find out
if this is a military of course it's a
military-style weapon what in the why
the [ __ ] would someone take any other
kind of gun into a shooting to kill
multiple people why why would they do
that
that's like taking a
a 1992 dodge caravan to a drag race
the [ __ ] are you talking about of course
of course they're going to get the best
weapon they can
to apply the maximum amount of damage
that's the point
well they're mentally ill yeah probably
you're not gonna do anything about that
either common ground susan collins you
dumb [ __ ]
if you want more of a reason
i don't know to participate in your
democracy and figure out uh how can we
work this around where the majority of
ideology
right the majority of american opinion
on policy not opinion anyways
just on policy like i don't know
common sense
gun safety
just common [ __ ] sense we did a whole
show on it yesterday
we had a former marine corps veteran
on and explaining to us
because i think it's important that
people know what these guns are
regardless if you hate them or love them
regardless if you don't you want them
banned and you don't want them
manufactured at all
or you love them and you think there
should be gazillions of them
you should listen
to someone who knows about these weapons
well he's skewed he's a libtard
yeah well here's the thing
his view on guns isn't liberal
his view on guns
is american
you're killing us
by putting these [ __ ] weapons
in the hands of people who should not
have them
how in the [ __ ] can't we figure this out
doors dildos it's porn
matt walsh wants to blame it on lgbtq
community destroying our country monkey
pots
all kinds of [ __ ] nonsense
it's the gun you dumb [ __ ]
it's the [ __ ] gun
it is not difficult
to understand
what is happening in this country it is
not
tony there's other country that have
these guns that don't have these
problems
they just they don't they ban backdoors
in porn they don't have porn they don't
have dildos they don't have condoms life
begins at a boner
and women can't vote don't you know this
that's what we need to do in this
country you understand what they're
trying to do right
you get it right you understand what
these fascists are trying to do
like matt walsh tucker carlson
greg abbott ron desantis
they're using your fear and your
arguments for guns
to do nothing
to spiral us into fascism a lot [ __ ]
quicker by blaming it on porn and dildos
and
trans people
and woke-ism
and woke teachers
and snowflakes as if they're not the
biggest snowflakes in the entire [ __ ]
world
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
it is the access to the gun the gun the
gun the gun the gun you dumb
[ __ ]
how can you tie fascism to people who
just want their second amendment right
it's not your second amendment right
it is not
your second amendment right to have the
weapons to go into a hospital
a grocery store
a school
a church a theater
a restaurant a bowling alley
an office building a post office
a community center it is not your
[ __ ] right
to access that gun as fast as possible
so you can go kill as many as possible
you are [ __ ] deluded
you are deranged you are a [ __ ] idiot
pluck your [ __ ] head out of your
goddamn ass
and you people out there who like the
second amendment who are on the same
page as most people in this country
you may be conservative you may consider
yourself a republican
there's only so much that this country's
going to take of this you understand
that right
you want to own your ar-15s you want to
have your second amendment right as you
see it
there's only so much this country's
gonna take
like they're eventually gonna vote for
the politicians that are gonna
absolutely be behind
overturning the second amendment we've
done that before in this country
i know people like oh tony you're being
ridiculous i'm dead [ __ ] serious
i'm not absolutely opposed to the second
amendment
but if you don't if you believe in it
and you want to own guns and you want to
have the ability to have guns in this
country because you're not the militia
you're not you're an individual you dumb
[ __ ]
they bastardized this amendment decades
ago
and turned it into something that it's
not not well regulated and and not a
militia
there's going to be a sea change against
you if you don't get to the
[ __ ] table [ __ ] quick
and i'm talking to the people out there
that own guns want to own guns believe
in the second amendment think it's their
god-given right whatever the [ __ ]
arguments they want to make
you better get to the table with the
people who want to do gun reform
and stop acting like you're on the side
of the people who want no reform
you better do it fast
because there's a hell of a [ __ ]
problem in this country
and the people in this country
regardless of their ideology are gonna
start to do something about it
they're gonna start to move they're
gonna start to vote and they're not
gonna vote for some dumb [ __ ]
whose answer to guns is backdoors
we're talking about hospitals and
grocery stores and their children's
elementary schools
you dumb [ __ ] what are you gonna turn
every [ __ ] building in this country
into a prison
you think that's realistic at this point
you think that's you think that's what
americans want you are a stupid bastard
if you think that's what americans want
one entry into every building
yeah that's a good idea oh [ __ ]
fantastic idea
let's put fences up razor wire you know
what's really look like a fascist state
you know for the people who bitched and
complain and moan and [ __ ] on and on
and on
during the pandemic
about private business and they get to
operate however the [ __ ] they want you
can't tell them and government can't
tell them what the [ __ ] to do boy they
sure are they sure on the bandwagon of
telling private businesses and [ __ ]
municipalities and hospitals what the
[ __ ] to do
they really are for some private
business and private organization
regulation right now aren't they
all to protect their [ __ ] pockets
it's all it is it's a handful of
[ __ ] in this country a handful
of families in this country that
manufacture these [ __ ] weapons
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
who gives a [ __ ]
let them go broke who gives a [ __ ] and
they're not going to go broke in the
first place
they have mountains of money on the top
of their mountains of guns
they're going to get military contracts
they're gonna continue to build these
weapons [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
why are we protecting a handful of
families in this country because they
load the pockets of the politicians and
the organizations that are willing to
protect them
it's the money folks it's the [ __ ]
money
that's why we can't do anything oh
receiving collins see yeah oh boy them
guns to learn their lesson we've not
found some common ground we found some
common ground i think on background you
are dumb [ __ ] if you think they're
you're just now just now finding common
ground on background checks you can just
now do that
you're a stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
think right now is the only time that
you found common ground on background
checks
dumbest thing i've ever heard of in my
[ __ ] life
there's a [ __ ] bill sitting there
there's a [ __ ] bill sitting there
it's a bare minimum bill it's not it
won't even [ __ ] stop a lot of this
[ __ ]
but if it stops one of them just [ __ ]
one of them it's [ __ ] worth it vote
on it you
dumbass but you won't
and they won't
because ultimately the fear of the gun
is a good cause for them it piles money
in their [ __ ] coffers
it makes sure that they get support
from crazy ass [ __ ] gun nuts
the craziest of the crazy so people are
fearful
i'm telling you people out there that
own guns want to own guns and are for
gun safety
and are for reasonable [ __ ] common
sense gun laws
like we were talking about yesterday on
the show which does not impede your
right to own a gun
you just have to prove to everyone else
that you aren't a [ __ ] bonehead
when you buy one of these [ __ ]
weapons of war
it's gonna go a lot further than that
to all you boneheads out there
i'm telling you you better get to the
table and stop letting the side of the
gun take your argument
they continue to do this
90 of people are for background checks
90 [ __ ] percent of people are for
background checks
yet um
it seems like a majority of those folks
that are for background checks their
arguments are the ones that the gun
lobby are using to prevent background
checks
you get it right you get the politics
right i talk about it all the time on
here there's two things in this country
there's policy which is government and
there's politics which is the [ __ ]
elections and getting people who write
the policies [ __ ] elected
two different things government and
elections policy and politics are two
separate things they are not the same
[ __ ] thing
and democrats liberals moderates and
independents need to start to [ __ ]
realize that these fascists understand
that hook line sinker they know that
[ __ ] put it in a peach tree dish cook
that [ __ ] and make you some
gazpacho
if you want evidence
stop letting these [ __ ]
gun manufacturers these gun lobbies who
you want to make sure that there's
background checks on these guns that
they manufacture and they're pushing
stop letting them use your argument
make a different [ __ ] argument
stop with the [ __ ] good guy bad guy
all that nonsense back door [ __ ] well
maybe maybe we need to harden schools
maybe we need to give teachers guns no
we do not
no we do not this is not the [ __ ]
wild west this is 2022. you [ __ ]
hell even in the wild west they didn't
allow guns in some cities in some
counties
gun-free zones
meanwhile
as they fight for the right of the gun
they take away the right of the woman
and that's not going to stop either
they want to cancel your voice they want
to shut you up
the cancel culture [ __ ]
it's always the same [ __ ] it's
the same [ __ ]
the same [ __ ] that want to ban
abortions
because oh children's lives we're
pro-life we don't want anyone to die
we gotta ban abortions so that way women
can't make medical decisions about a
clump of cells
we want to save lives save the children
it's the same dumb [ __ ]
that are like pew pew pew pew we gotta
have these guns that kill humans
that are designed to kill as many humans
as possible because we're pro-life and
we want to save the children
because the only thing that stops a good
good compass cell with guns is a bad
clump of cell with guns
whatever
yep
happened again it's gonna happen again
too oh before the end of the weekend
we'll have another at least at least
three to five people killed in a
location with a mass shooting with one
of these weapons 100
no doubt that'll happen by the end of
the weekend
mark my words
i i don't have a crystal ball i say
doubt me but that this is not this is
not [ __ ] rocket science
it's asking does a bear [ __ ] in the
woods of course it does i mean unless
it's in a zoo and then it's [ __ ] in
the zoo it's not complicated to
understand
it's not rocket surgery it really isn't
you [ __ ] boneheads
it's the [ __ ] gun the
[ __ ] gun
every single time it's the [ __ ] gun
and susan collins with her little what
whatever the [ __ ]
she thinks she's doing here
by
gaslighting america because that's
really what she's doing they're [ __ ]
they're they're really they're really
just trying to distract us that yes
there is something being done there's
something then do it
do it
susan collins call press conference and
get nine other republicans nine
nine other republicans to stand in front
of a microphone with you and with chuck
schumer and say hey we will vote for
this [ __ ] bill on background checks
that's the least we could do at this
point
do it
do
it stop talking about it do the
[ __ ] work
because it's all talk until you do the
work and i don't trust that [ __ ]
not one i don't trust that [ __ ]
i don't even see how mane anyone in
maine can trust that [ __ ] [ __ ]
she whines and complains about sidewalk
chalk
acts like it's the most dangerous thing
that's ever happened in the entire
[ __ ] world
19 children and two teachers get
slaughtered down in uvalde and she
gaslights us that hey something might be
being done
it's too bad it's too bad that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] psycho down in ubaldi
didn't ride on the sidewalk with chalk
susan collins would be down there
investigating and banning that chalk
immediately [ __ ] immediately she'd
have a bill on the [ __ ] senate floor
to ban sidewalk chalk
in in the united states of america no
way would she put up with sidewalk chalk
being written down in front of an
elementary school threatening those
students
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
we don't believe you dummy
when we don't trust you you [ __ ]
dummy
shoes and collins
and guns learn their lesson
now republicans are going to sit back
and use their thoughts
not their prayers their thoughts to
think about
supporting some sort of common sense
reform
that would prevent these things from
happening only think about it though
we're only going to think about it we're
not going to do anything i mean that
would actually mean that we would have
to go against the gun lobby which then
they would then they would knock our nra
rating oh that would be horrible
horrible horrible stuff
them pesky nra voters would vote against
us who gives a [ __ ]
did you see that [ __ ] auditorium in
houston it was it was half empty
couldn't even fit couldn't even fill a
[ __ ] auditorium
in [ __ ] texas for the nra
your support is waning
and if you can hear me out there if
you're a conservative or you're a gun
owner and you [ __ ] hate my guts
because of the [ __ ] i say and the stance
that i take but you're like well
you know this gun reform gun safety
makes sense get off your [ __ ] ass and
join me
how i'll lock arms with you i don't give
a [ __ ]
i could care less if you're a [ __ ]
fascist or not
if we can if we can make these
[ __ ] to get these [ __ ] guns
out of our [ __ ] schools out of our
goddamn grocery stores out of our
[ __ ] hospitals
you god damn right i'll join you let's
do that [ __ ]
i mean fascists won't join me in that
that's why they're a fascist
but i know there's common sense gun
owners out there that want to own these
guns that own plenty of these guns that
want these reforms now they want them
now
because i think a lot of them understand
that if they don't have them now and
they don't do something now their their
their ability their privilege to own
these guns may be gone quick
get to the table negotiate stop letting
the [ __ ] crazies use your arguments
to support the gun
and to support the abolishment
the abolition of any kind of gun safety
jesus christ this 18 year old in uvalde
walked into a store
and they gave him two [ __ ] guns 17
rounds of ammunition and he didn't have
to pay a single [ __ ] cent
and then he went and slaughtered 19 kids
and two teachers
and the cops are [ __ ] the cops are
[ __ ]
covering something up who the [ __ ] knows
what's going on with that
probably more more cover-up to make sure
that the good guys don't look like the
bad guys
with guns
i would say that's the [ __ ] fix here
down there in evaldi with the police
department
so again if you can hear me
you may hate my [ __ ] guts fine
whatever i don't give a [ __ ]
but if you are on the side
of gun safety and common sense [ __ ]
regulations just common sense [ __ ] just
common sense [ __ ] that all americans are
for
they're for it 80 90 of americans are
for this common sense type stuff
and here's what you got to do you got to
stop letting the gun nuts use your
arguments
to get the exact opposite
stop talking about your stupid [ __ ]
arguments about your second amendment
and militia and blah blah blah blah blah
and your dumb stupid [ __ ] arguments i
am sick and tired of someone coming up
in comments saying well i'm for gun
reform but you can't take these guns
away it's our second amendment right and
blah blah blah and we have the but we
have to tyrannical government and this
and that
they're using
you
to get the opposite of what you say you
want just like [ __ ] stupid-ass rule
white people out there republicans have
been using stupid rule white people for
[ __ ] decades and decades and decades
with abortion
and guns and god
to take away the [ __ ] that they want
and not do the [ __ ] they want
like make sure they have good hospitals
good rural hospitals good rural schools
nice roads
manufacturing economies they've taken it
all away from you because you are you
you are so easily deluded
you dumb [ __ ] they are using
you to make their arguments against you
that's what they're doing
you own guns you're you're a
law-abiding citizen who owns guns
they're using and you want reform
so people are safe they're using your
arguments yours you
to do the thing that you did not do the
thing that you want them to do
it's time this country plucked their
head
out of their [ __ ] ass
stick with us we'll be right back
right after these messages and we'll
surf the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends we have some [ __ ] to go through
today
stick around we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us through the
break we're gonna serve the tweety boots
in the journey drink what do you guys
think
i wanna i wanna get to some news here of
course we know the news in tulsa uh
where um people were murdered
by a gun yesterday
jesus christ we got it we're gonna do
this every [ __ ] day it seems like
again by the weekend we'll have another
one of these shootings by the weekend
sometime by sunday night there'll be one
trust me i don't know where to be
concert who knows bowling alley who
knows grocery store who knows a walmart
it's hard to tell it's hard to tell
because it could be anywhere in this
country
all you gotta do is drive to one of
these fascist states
get you a gun and go back to another
state if you want to it's the pure
simple fact of it
but we got a lot of news to get to
a lot of important [ __ ] in the world
um
did you guys hear yesterday did you hear
there was a johnny depp trial i had no
idea
i had no idea i actually have not been
paying attention this [ __ ] um
but apparently
uh johnny depp won his trial i guess i
guess they both kind of won but you know
whatever
again who gives a [ __ ] rants ass the
best part about this news is that that
[ __ ] is finally over with we do not
have to concentrate on that nonsense
not one other single minute
well
i mean besides right now besides like
right now
it happens um there's a couple videos i
want to show you here
and this one here walter pointed it out
to everyone let me make this bigger here
please support booker for kentucky in
this fight to defeat rand paul and this
is one of the
man this is one of the
most powerful campaign commercials that
i've seen in a long time it even gives a
content warning
the video contains strong imagery ooh
baby that's just perfect for us here on
this podcast don't you think a viewer
discretion is advised i love it
let's see what he has to say this is
this is some powerful [ __ ] watch this
the pain of our past
persists to this day
in kentucky like many states throughout
the south lynching was a tool of terror
it was used to kill hopes for freedom
it was used to kill
my ancestors
now in a historic victory for our
commonwealth i have become the first
black kentuckian to receive the
democratic nomination for u.s senate
my opponent
the very person who compared expanded
health care to slavery
the person who said he would have
opposed the civil rights act
the person who single-handedly blocked
an anti-lynching act from being federal
law
the choice couldn't be clearer
do we move forward together or do we let
politicians like rand paul forever hold
us back and drive us apart
in november
we will choose healing
we will choose
kentucky
god damn
charles booker for us senate that is a
hell of an ad don't you guys think
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's an ad
that's a hell of an ad i think
i think democrats if they want to get if
they want to get more attention
they're going to have to be they're
going to have to be a little more
provocative and
walter points out that yes that is very
a very provocative ad
um
let's uh let's let's keep that going and
let's keep
let's
let's be provocative as [ __ ]
let's get him on the run it's enough of
this garbage
it's enough of it speaking of uh
[Music]
provocative films here's one from 11
films production that was putting out um
about some of the mass shootings here's
another provocative one keep going with
this stuff let's watch
[Music]
i'm done okay i'm done i've had it they
[ __ ] failed our kids again
you know how many more times
i had hoped
[Music]
when i became president i would not have
to do this
again
[Music]
to lose a child
it's like having a piece of your soul
ripped away
[Applause]
every time i think about those kids
it gets me mad
there's a hollowness in your chest you
feel like you're being sucked into an
answer
how am i going to plan a funeral
what kind of casket i have to write a
eulogy
[Music]
all i did
was send it to school
[Music]
90 of us are living under the tyranny of
ten percent
sit down you're out of line they seem
angrier and better or worse than they
were at the massacre of 19 children and
two fourth grade teachers
and i'm trying to figure out at what
point in time this became so normalized
the ar-15
shreds the human body just think about
that
think about what that would do to a
little 10 year old body
what in god's name do you need a solvent
for except to kill someone
[Music]
and you read their age 10
10
10. i have a fourth grader
and
uh she put her hands
in her friend's blood and then smeared
it she said all over her body she wanted
to look like she was dead
what are we doing
and we were all hiding behind the stage
what are we doing
[Music]
he said bro red flag
why only in america it is just an
american problem sir
america
right now
[Music]
you're working
[Music]
yeah i was bullied in school too i never
shot up my [ __ ] classmates next
[ __ ] excuse
[Music]
so honestly
to hell with anybody who says don't
politicize this
[Music]
this is about semi-automatic weapons and
military weapons that are killing our
children in school
[Music]
it's up to you it's your choice
you can sit at home
you can let the republicans win
you can do that and they'll continue
this and this nonsense
trust me they will they're they're
this [ __ ] that susan cowan's talking
about that
that ain't happening
that ain't that ain't gonna [ __ ]
happen it's not gonna happen
this nonsense about how they're gonna
come up with some kind of common sense
[ __ ] common ground [ __ ] no no
no they're not that's all nonsense it's
all [ __ ]
so let's move on to some more news
uh we got some new stuff trending
michael avenatti is trending apparently
i know we'll run back into this this
shooting thing don't worry we'll run
right back into it it's not it's not
gonna stop
and then it's not gonna stop me from
talking about it definitely here on the
tony michael's podcast
i'm not gonna quit i'm not gonna shut up
i'm not gonna stop yelling i'm not gonna
stop screaming i'm not gonna stop
ranting it ain't gonna happen
rather it's about [ __ ] taking rights
away from women
taking consent away from parents banning
macbooks
wanting to marry children or just pure
blooded murder that they want to put
guns in the hands of people who are
going to mow down your children mow down
hospital patients mow down black people
in a goddamn grocery store
yeah i'm going to [ __ ] yell and
scream about it every [ __ ] day every
goddamn day monday through friday every
[ __ ] one of them
and if you want to listen to that
because we've got a ton of new listeners
if you want to listen
youtube twitter twitch go subscribe to
the youtube page do not forget
to subscribe to the youtube page because
if you miss an episode they're all there
they're all there and if you if you're
on the run
and you want to listen to yelling and
screaming the cathartic
anger
on every single one of these issues of
these fascists because it's all the same
people it's the same [ __ ] the
same [ __ ] that want to tell
women they can't make their medical
choices are the same [ __ ] that
want to make sure psychos have access
easy [ __ ] access
to weapons of war to to murder your
[ __ ] children
if you want if you want to hear it just
keep listening
download on apple spotify and google i
will yell and scream into this
microphone every single day
every one of them i'm not gonna stop
and neither is gabe sanchez he's not
gonna stop either he's not he's not
going to stop
i don't know you're going to stop you're
a little late i i'm guessing you're
still finishing up your uh
we got a you got another segment coming
right i do have another segment
folks he's got another segment coming
and i think it has to do with uh the nra
convention right is it the yeah yeah
okay yeah so it covers well you have a
couple coming but this is the one that
this next one will be on the nra yeah
this one is um
on trump's speech
okay some of the some of the suggestions
that he's made that we've heard again
and again regurgitated from the gop
and some dumb ass remarks that ted cruz
made about
the elite
right gabe i i heard that this hospital
had a lot of doors and that's probably
the problem that they just this hospital
in tulsa they had a lot of doors there
was a lot of places to go in and out it
is a hospital
i would imagine that a hospital should
have a single entry a 36 inch door with
heavily armed guards that's probably
what we need to do i mean i was told
that nurses and both doctors get an
ak-47 or potentially no no no no no no
no the patients need to be issued a
pistol
when and flak jackets when they are
admitted to the hospital that [ __ ] is
part of the admissions process so the
hospital gives it not the insurance
company
well
listen this is this is this is
you think this is funny about these
arguments but this is some of the
arguments that they might start making i
mean here's the thing i mean america is
the only country where you could get
shot
and then like you could america is the
only company where you could be in
school get shot go to the hospital to be
treated and then get shot again like
that is the reality we live in right a
church isn't safe a school isn't safe a
hospital isn't safe like when you live
in a country where all these places that
you at one point thought
no one's gonna realistically come in
here with a gun and try to shoot at the
place well
every day we learn something new and
republicans won't do anything about it
to change it
i i guess the story is this morning that
this the person the the
deranged person who had easy access to
firearms that they want they want him to
have easy access to burns by the way you
know they keep saying all that we don't
want crazy people have access yeah you
do yes you do yeah if if you don't then
do something about it using money good
[ __ ]
they want teacher zone guns they want
doctors and nurses and patients don't it
means more money like you said that's
more guns yeah
i guess apparently he had a beef with
one of the doctors inside this hospital
or clinic or whatever it's a hospital i
guess but he went to the clinic side or
something i don't know it's hard to
understand at this point um you know the
good guys with the guns are really
trying to make sure they're not accused
of being bad guys with guns do we know
if he was upset like just this is just a
hypothetical let's say that he was upset
because he got a bill because the
healthcare no no apparently it was he
had us at the reports are this morning
now these could change especially if
they're getting this information from
the good guys with the guns right law
enforcement we've seen that in uvalde
but apparently um this tulsa incident he
was mad because
of a surgery that a doctor did it didn't
turn out the way that it was supposed to
or something he was upset about a
procedure that had happened with the
doctor um and that was his
rampage that he went to to kill
however many people he could kill um and
i'm not sure the circumstance again yeah
by the time we get to the weekend
there's going to be another one of these
shootings and we're going to lose track
right of what happened in tulsa what
happened in uvalde because it's all
going to mesh together right i mean
there was like three or four i think on
on monday on memorial day
right well yeah so like three of them
all at the same goddamn time
all at the same time and and some of
them were just incidents with a gun
where they it was a potential match uh
active shooter i mean yesterday we you
know i live in l.a we had one in van
nuys which is not too far from where i
live at a high school so like
you know
any every every single day it is you
know somewhere new it is you know it
it's it's one of those things it'll
never happen here and then sure enough
the next day it happens in the spot that
you thought it would never happen
right well and it's going to continue
it's not it's not going to stop this
isn't this isn't going to quit
right like like the only way to stop
this is not to find common ground in a
in a body political body and then brag
about how you've seen common ground and
not vote on the bill that has common
ground this is all [ __ ] stop talking
about your common ground the bill that's
sitting there get nine other [ __ ]
senators susan collins in front of a
microphone with chuck schumer and say
hey we're willing to vote on this common
ground bill start talking about common
ground and go out in front of a
microphone and tell mitch mcconnell to
go [ __ ] himself yeah go [ __ ] yourself
nra go [ __ ] yourself mitch mcconnell
we're gonna vote on this background
check bill regardless if the handful of
families who manufacture weapons in this
country want it or not because that's
the rub that's a rub there's a handful
of [ __ ] families in this
country that don't want these background
checks
they want they want the gun show
loophole
they want they want people to be able to
buy a [ __ ] gun with a credit card
that's what they want right it is
at the end of the day like it's not you
know gun control or gun reform or
whatever like it's just gun safety it is
gun
safety at the end of the day
what we are trying to do is ensure that
there's gun safety because right now
it's the [ __ ] wild west
anyone who's anyone can get a gun
they can go wherever they want with a
gun
some places you don't even need a permit
to have a gun like in texas
but again and again
we're proven
that the republican way of not
regulating something
shits the bed and we get [ __ ] over and
then when we get [ __ ] over the
republicans republicans go well i mean
listen we don't we don't want to go over
over too much on the rights we don't
want to come for your guns
we'll come for your rights we'll come
for your fallopian tubes
right but ppu we won't go for your guns
well you know again there's there's
there's not big money there's not a
handful of families that are making big
money um off of uh fallopian tubes in
this country right um you know like they
are the
[Music]
the weapons speaking of of making money
apparently michael avenatti received a
four-year prison term
um for defrauding client stormy daniels
the porn actor
who uh capitulated him to fame
uh catapulted him skewed to fame of
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in book proceeds so it sounds like um
michael avenatti has received
his second sentence here because he
received his first sentence for the uh
for the nike case right yeah so he's
gonna get another four year i mean this
is insane i guess you know whatever i
mean
every day again is another surprise but
you know
this was one was like oh [ __ ] like
this guy is representing stormy daniels
and we've got a case here to like you
know prove trump actually was the one
who issued that 130 000 dollars you know
and then you find out oh he was trying
to extort uh
nike and then he actually was you know
defrauding stormy daniels he's like oh
man [ __ ] man is anyone good anymore
well so here's what i'll tell you about
michael avenatti michael avenatti is a
[ __ ] box he was a [ __ ] box from the
beginning now regardless of who was on
his [ __ ] list as far as who he was
gonna get he had a vendetta against
trump and that was to like like this
says catapult him to fame right right
now
michael avenatti used a lot of tactics
as michael cohen and donald trump used
like that's though that that he used
those tactics and the media loved him
just like they love [ __ ] trump
this just shows you this just shows you
because you know they're going to say oh
tony you must be a michael avenatti fan
well i mean
i i'm for the truth which is that
michael avenatti wanted to get the truth
out about the check that was written to
stormy daniels
which it it came to light and then
michael cohen
in a congressional hearing
actually gave us the copy of the [ __ ]
check that was signed by donald trump
while he was president-elect while he
was already elected it was signed by him
saying yeah
i want to pay her off to keep her mouth
shut now michael avenatti took advantage
of that situation just like donald trump
takes advantage of every situation
yeah he was he's a trumper he's a
[ __ ] he he's an he's a trumper who
who saw being anti-trump and taking
advantage of a woman
and the advantage of a woman who was a
victim
of [ __ ] of intimidation tactics by
the trump team
he saw an opportunity to to defraud her
and he's been sentenced to a four-year
prison term uh in that respect now i'm
sure michael avenatti will
will appeal this decision right but um
you know i i you know
i'm not gonna be on a michael avenatti
train because michael avenatti tried to
take down trump he he did it on the back
of stormy daniels and some people say
well [ __ ] she shouldn't be held up high
why not
why not she came out she told the truth
she wanted the truth to be told
why not just because she's a poor known
star just because she does work that you
don't necessarily agree with
stop being jd vance stop being jd vance
stop judging people
i mean
what it's not even that it's not even
like the you know i think it's people
who are like oh that's so you know it's
so dirty whatever it's also probably
the porn yeah yeah right you've seen her
have you seen her born have you searched
your porn i have in the past
no no no no no no come on come on come
on come on so so were you a stormy
daniels fan before
the whole
no honestly like i don't know porn stars
so i didn't know stormy daniels until
this all came out don't give me that i
swear i'm not saying no one personally
i'm saying right right right you know
they're no i honestly i mean
i don't know anyone by name so i don't
know who they are would you but i looked
at it would you be faster would you be
fascinated if if there were porn stars
that watched your content
oh that would be awesome i mean would
you be awesome
right
and and you could do an exchange right
yeah i mean i'll watch your content yeah
yeah i'll watch you look i doubt in the
scheme i down in the grand scheme
they're like i can't wait for this one
person gabe to watch everyone all the
other millions of people who watch me
forget them but i just need this one
person to watch right i mean if they
value my work and my opinion that i
would be super honored i would i would
love
to know if stormy daniels watches gabe
sanchez's content i would love to know
that i mean that would be something
here's the thing i do have i do have a
sketch that i have not
made yet it is is it stormy no no no
it's not stormy i didn't know if it was
like it is a it is a porn it is a porn
sketch it's a funny sketch though wait
wait wait wait wait even even like like
with with josh holly and jd vance this
still hasn't been released yet it still
hasn't been released i just need the
time
to actually film it but it's one of
those like that you know the pizza guy
shows up at the door and the girl oh
yeah yeah is that your favorite kind of
porn is that your favorite yeah that's
the you know it's like that's your
ketchup that's yours
right i love pizza were you a pizza
delivery boy where did you deliver no i
never i never was i did you always
wanted to though because of this porn
yeah i was just delivering tacos that's
what i was doing oh you know well you
know pizza tacos you know you could you
could kind of you know right but i but i
i will say like
uh if she does watch my stuff thank you
you know yeah um but like i said i don't
know porn stars by name so i didn't know
who she was until it came out and wait
wait how do you know him how do you know
him you said you don't know him by name
how do you know him
i
how do you identify
porn stars we want to know
what i mean to say is i don't know them
by name right so that's what i want how
do you know them how do what do you know
them by like when you recognize them how
do you recognize them
but not by name but by one i don't know
i don't know i just go oh hey look
that's that point anybody anybody else
want to see gabe's search history on
pornhub now i do yeah i definitely do
yeah you know you know i know jd
i'm a wholesome boy you know
nothing crazy i don't have any weird
kink [ __ ] with two ways
gabe sanchez is searching pizza party
pizza delivery boy on pornhub yeah i i
bet jd vance would like your search
history on bournemouth i'm sure i'm sure
he would i'm sure he would i'm sure
nothing crazy you know josh holly
probably not it's probably it's probably
way too not weird it's not weird enough
for josh josh hawley i guarantee i
guarantee josh everyone's like gabe is
blushing i'm not blushing it's just the
pink in the background it is just
accentuating the colors of my face right
but what i will say is josh hawley i
guarantee is one of those guys who looks
up real kink like [ __ ] okay i'm not i'm
not i'm not shaming i'm not king shaming
but i wouldn't be surprised
if he was trying to you know look at you
know bible thumpers and slappers you
know like that was the that was the key
term
you mean they use like they use like uh
a bible to spank someone or something
yeah you know or or he you know it's
like one of those people who like to
inflict pain you know like kind of like
a bdsm like like like dominatrix type
stuff yeah exactly like biblical
biblical yeah this is like oh i'm not
you know i'm your god you know it's like
real [ __ ] write that down i need to
go search that later biblical dominatrix
i need to put that in i'm sure it exists
honestly i mean i think there's anything
for anyone out there
especially josh hawley and especially jd
vance you know despite their own kind of
internal struggle and insecurity right i
think there is a porn for anyone see see
folks the listeners out there gabe has
really got us off track we want to know
how you identify when you're when how do
you recognize yes i don't know
this person has blonde hair this person
has brown hair who knows yeah [ __ ]
oh you're searching blonde burnett he's
getting he's got a brown
blonde
there you go he's got a preference he's
got a preference no i i really um again
this whole stormy daniels thing um i
actually you know and i don't hold her
up as some kind of hero too i just think
she wanted her story to be told right i
just think she wanted her story to be
told that michael he took advantage of
her and seen a way to make money um off
her telling her story and took advantage
of it and defrauded her um just the same
way the same way
that that trump would have done to
anyone else and that he has done to
everyone else yeah that's that's just
the that's just the bureau i mean it
takes one to no one right right and just
because michael avenatti wanted to take
down trump it may have been because he
wanted a profit off taking down right
that that and in that one moment i was
like oh [ __ ]
maybe we've got something and then you
find out what he was doing in the
background you're like oh [ __ ]
maybe we don't have anything
it
you're not you're not you're not gonna
get the best of people sometimes in this
country for sure um wells fargo is in
the news apparently um the employees are
pushing to organize a union across the
bank's workforce and this this
unionizing stuff is getting more and
more popular gabe yeah it's crazy it's
almost like the pandemic taught people
that they should value themselves and
their own kind of worth right we've seen
it you know starbucks you got wells
fargo here other places that would
typically be a non-union function
and people who would be said you know
long hours low pay
now
are saying we actually have a voice
and we're coming to the table and we're
telling you our demands and you have and
we have to be heard
right and it's awesome to see this it is
great it isn't i mean it's taken a while
but i'm glad to see it
well you know the union was popular in
this country for for many many decades
um and that's one of the reasons why we
actually have the insurance
debacle that we have now because way
back when unions really fought because
there wasn't a public option of a health
care right you had to privately buy it
so what unions were trying to do was
incorporate it into their benefits for
their jobs because these companies were
really trying to compete and so were the
unions trying to compete for these
workers and one of the best ways to gain
workers at the time was health insurance
because it was much more affordable way
back when there wasn't as many political
excuse me uh medical
medical procedures there wasn't the
politics in health insurance right so it
was kind of a new type thing so it was
very affordable back then so it was an
easy way for unions and employers to
offer employees to to to compete for
that labor because gabe that's really
what is happening right now in this
economy right and that's what we're
seeing with these push for unions
it's like you said during the pandemic
and and even after now in this heated
economy in this inflated economy
workers are realizing that hey i can
trade my labor somewhere else for much
more money right right like that's
somebody is willing to pay for the
skills that i have and are willing to
pay market rate or above right to what
i'm worth to to gain my employment and
to get my labor i will trade my labor
and i think a lot of a lot of folks have
finally understood
that you don't have to be told by
someone what your labor's worth you go
out and and negotiate the deal that's
best for the labor that you want to
trade exactly right so because it is a
free market capitalist society that's
what we live in and you are able to
trade your labor sometimes in the public
sector sometimes in the private sector a
lot of times in the private sector and
and the way that a lot of people want to
protect their negotiations is through a
collective group and and using a union
mm-hmm so i think people are becoming
more aware and and i i really think um
that more because the union has really
been a part of the democratic
establishment for years right um but we
seen a shift in
uh in union back candidates when trump
came along and the reason why is because
there was a lot of disgruntled um
in-cell type white dudes that are in
unions especially in the rust belt
and that kind of weirdly put this
situation where republicans almost had
to capitulate to unions but they're not
here um and the reason why is because
joe biden is the most pro-union uh
president that we've ever had like
outright like he
maybe not maybe not behind closed doors
which i actually think he's just as pro
union behind closed doors is what he
says right
out to the public i think that's one
thing that is kind of misguided by joe
biden that what he says is something
that he doesn't actually like i actually
think that the guy just says whatever he
actually feels come on man well we see
it we seen it when he was the vice
president yeah yeah totally when when uh
president obama really wasn't ready
politically
to say
gay marriage should
be
it should be a right right lgbt
community should be able to marry
whoever they want and joe biden was the
first to come to the map for them on
meet the press which surprised everybody
but i don't think it should be
surprising with joe biden he just he
really does say
what he wants to say right good bad or
indifferent that's why he's always had
the gaffe that's why he's not that great
of an order is because he just says what
he wants and he is pro-union and i
believe that's why he visually seems to
be the most pro-union president is
because he's just saying the things that
he wants to say how he wants to support
he's not putting a lot of political
calculation right to his support for
unions his his staff would like him to
right right probably not doing that it's
crazy you know again it's radical to
support
unions it's radical to support people
collectively bargaining
their labor
i mean look you look across the board
right and you're like uh republicans
want um
you know free market capitalism and
that's what they want and then you're
like okay fine you want that these
people are part of the market and
they've established that there is a
corner of the market that they want to
be created here which is a union and
they want union representation now you
could have people like elon musk who
like over years i've been you know uh
against unions and uh it's actually bad
for business no it's not it is not bad
for business it creates it is regulation
it creates standards reliability
uh uh liability which keeps companies
alive for years to come why do you think
we still have ford motor and chevrolet
like those companies would have been out
of business decades ago if the unions
wouldn't have been there to prop them up
right this is all really [ __ ] dumb
and stupid like
this is really stupid to think that the
unions didn't have something to do with
the ford motor company still existing
right or the or chevrolet or even or
even chrysler for that matter yeah i
mean the other thing too is you've got
there's a well i do want to call it
really quick there was a super chat
that we got while we were talking
uh
gabe on the production board
dave on the production board
i think i might let him run it more
folks even though he's boy i need to get
the i need to get a control pad so i'm
not doing it for my mom i know i know uh
it comes from midas margie
thank you so much
we love you you got another one there oh
we got another one yeah thank you again
uh oh uh kathy wants to uh
remind everybody about the uh january 6
live stream we are we are going to um
we're going to live stream the january
6th select but we're also thinking about
um streaming some of the march of our
lives on june 11th on washington you
guys tell us what you think about that
if you want us to stream some of that um
there's a march of our lives and i think
mom's on demand and several other groups
are going to be part of that march on dc
um so we're thinking about streaming
that one as well
trying to get some of these events to
you with our commentary you guys kind of
like that stuff you guys like the
marjorie taylor green
hearing that we streamed with our
commentary we had karen at difficult
from legal af that day which karen she
was there for like 45 minutes you can
actually go
watch that um
that that stream and watch karen in a
shorter version you don't have to watch
the whole eight hours yeah on youtube go
check that out um and subscribe to the
youtube channel if you're on facebook
you guys know we stream to um youtube
twitter and twitch live every single
weekday monday through friday but we
also simulcast to the facebook page of
midas touch so if you're over there the
link to the youtube's right at the top
of the post so come over and
check out check out the youtube channel
um
oh we have you're you're closing another
one thank you deirdre yeah thank you
very much
we're really close to uh burbank heyo
burbank airport i saw this trending
earlier what is this
we have a smaller airport in burbank
which honestly i would fly out of and i
do probably ninety percent of the time
that i fly
um
i text you last night that uh uh we had
a birthday dinner for my daughter last
night and well you didn't text me about
your birthday jennifer no no i i was i
was texting you at while
last summer we went to your hometown we
went to chicago last year yeah yeah yeah
which was fantastic this also brings up
the possibility that we could do an
episode oh you mean like live in in
person yeah we could do a live in
perspective don't don't don't threaten
me don't threaten me don't throw me with
a good time [ __ ] threat me with that
kind of [ __ ] i'm just saying she's
threatening me i'm just saying if you
come no yeah we could maybe we could do
something like that yeah but but should
i fly in the burn bank i mean chris here
is
so in my experience
it depends on where you're staying and
it all depends on where you're coming
from right so like burbank is a smaller
airport it is a very short wait time to
go through security which is great even
if you have um
uh pre-check but beyond that
um i also would recommend burbank just
because it's just
i don't know it's a it's not as crazy
you know it's not lax which is an
international hub you can go to lax and
you might find uh cheaper flights but
you could also find stuff through
burbank which is like south so what's
what's flying oh okay
the cheapest flights
seem to be uh what what's this what's
the theory yeah yeah oh my god the other
one where you basically pay for your
breath in the plane right right you're
sitting on a milk crate with a right
yeah
i have flown
spirit and i will continue to fly spirit
whenever i'm like i need the cheapest
flight from
especially when i'm going from la and i
need to go into chicago right depending
on what they think
do they go to chicago because they go to
st louis i know there's like red yeah
they go into
so
the i think spirit flies into
maybe o'hare but they probably fly into
um so does spirit go to midway no
no no no no spirit doesn't go into
burbank
it's not burbank's not even good enough
for spirit that's well it's maybe it's
too good it's too good
we don't need to bring us down it's way
too classy for for spirits yeah i just
seen burbank was trending i figured we'd
ask gabe right i saw that tweet and i
was gonna respond and i'm like here i'm
just gonna be
you know one other speck of noise in the
whole thing someone else will say
something that basically explains the
story i mean i don't live too far it's a
nice like 20 to 30 minute drive from the
airport
and then from there
like when i used to fly into sf because
i uh i used to work out of a company nsf
uh right before i left sf that's the
other place my family said san francisco
or la that's where they yeah i think
they might want to they might want to
want better weather come to l.a
sf is beautiful i love sf yeah they went
to they went and seen the golden and my
my wife and my son were oh yeah able to
go to see the golden gate bridge yeah so
we've got alcatraz golden gate bridge
you've got the new bay bridge that has
the lights at night you know right right
um i thought you were trying to get me
to come to l.a not san francisco yeah
yeah yeah i'm saying you come to l.a man
but anyway i was saying on the airport
it depends
it depends on where you're going but
yeah i used to fly out of burbank into
sf and i would be round trip from my
door to the office door that i worked at
i would say
[Music]
less than three hours
right so you could get on the plane in
the morning and be there before
lunchtime exactly pretty much i'd show
up be like hey we're getting lunch i've
been great you know oh well
speaking of flights and gas
i don't know i'm trying i'm trying the
transition here yeah yeah yeah oh opec
is number 20. um
opec and its allies agree to a bigger
than expected oil production increase of
648 000 barrels
a day in july and august
so it looks like opec is going to
increase their production on purpose to
lower the cost of fuel huh who who would
imagine that opec controls the cost of
fuel because they control the production
around the world that's kind of funny i
i could have never dreamed that up that
that it's not that that the inflated gas
prices and some of these inflated prices
and this inflation isn't joe biden's
fault like joe biden is responsible for
eight percent inflation in europe oh i'm
sure of that yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here well all the
people who are like oh i'm a free market
capitalist and da da da da da and this
is right like but they don't even know
yeah they don't remember like here's the
thing opec
is like
economics 101 right when you learn it's
a case study you're like hey what's a
monopoly oh it's opec right they're the
ones who control
and dictate the prices of gas and to be
clear opec is not part of free market
capitalist right no yeah it's crony
capitalism at its [ __ ] exactly right
at its best
but yeah it is it continues to be
something that is studied but the funny
thing is whenever you have these bros
these [ __ ] finance bros who come in
and say well actually the prices are
based on the policies that binding has
passed and it's like okay look there are
incremental changes that we can make
within the us and we've pretty much just
exploited all of them to lower gas
prices in this time whether it's
reserves or it's maybe a tax a gas tan
or like a gas credit you know there are
other things that we could do but it's
very nominal on the grand scheme the
bigger players which is [ __ ] opec
which biden is not a part of or has any
say or control over is the are the
people that can actually fluctuate the
prices up or down in drastic ways so you
know i love it when uh when a good
finance bro on twitter is like uh it's
based on that it's like shut the [ __ ] up
dude you don't know what you're talking
about right and you read something
pipeline you read some yeah
wall street op-ed where someone guy says
oh it's actually the wall street uh
permit streaming permit yeah the
keystone the keystone pipeline like the
dude the thing wasn't even built for
what you're talking about well no the
keystone pipeline was built well the xl
the excel that alright the little
addition that they wanted to make the
one that was not going to give us
anything right we're just going to run
everywhere even even once it was done
and completed and and crude was running
through that [ __ ] it wasn't going to
give us anything right that almost all
that [ __ ] was going to go to china in
the first place the other thing i would
also bring up is during
the the cold snap the winter freeze that
happened in texas
you mean the one where they had uh
cancun
right you know the privatized grid that
has failed multiple times and has brown
outs throughout the year
those cancun tickets were on sale i know
it was a deal but it was also a family
deal he had to go because it was a good
dad that's right
but i will say this is
when it comes to the the the freeze the
winter storm we lost
product
because the [ __ ] plant
couldn't handle the weather
because we even though we had had
something similar in the past they said
oh guys we're fine it'll never happen
again babe you you act like you act like
private industry runs on the electrical
grid that everyone contributes to
this is almost yo don't you know don't
you know those private companies they
built that they built that yeah yeah and
they may build that yeah yeah they're
the ones we need to keep it privatized
because clearly
the privatization of of the electric
grid that they have in texas has worked
it hasn't failed never we don't need
regulation speaking of [ __ ] shitbox
in texas louie gohmert's trending
apparently he said he's done he's over
apparently it's something on camera is
that i don't know what what what is this
hi this is it
this has got to be like 46 minutes ago
yeah let's see uh gomer
biden for using god's name in vain and
blames the 60s this guy's blamed
he blames the 60s for mass shootings are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me this is going to be
great man
this i mean look at this guy does he
even have teeth left they all fall out i
mean wasn't wasn't he also the one that
blamed the moon
no no no no no no no he wanted he wanted
a certain agency to figure out
how they could change the orbit oh right
that's what it was yeah right right
because the orbit of the moon is
creating climate change so they need to
figure out how to change it maybe i
don't know maybe nuke it like that i
don't know that here that is how dumb
these things are i can't even remember
all of the dumb [ __ ] they say i'm like i
remember it had to do with the moon
right i can't remember the specifics as
to the
actual
dumb [ __ ] answer response suggestion
that they made because every time he
talks
it is
wow but i'm super glad that he put his
position at risk and decided to run for
ag and is no longer gonna be a
representative so hey that's a win right
there
perfect that's the only good thing that
ken paxton has done we'll just say
what's that
is made sure that
yeah
i don't i don't know about that i mean
you're giving a lot of credit there man
that's
that's credit i'm not willing to give
you may give it but i'm not going to
let's listen let's listen to [ __ ]
toothless gomer here um talk about gun
legislation i'm sure it's going to be
brilliant yeah i i think back
historically we had a president
in franklin roosevelt that on d-day led
the country in a six to eight minute
prayer
for our troops
and now we had a president come on after
uvalde
and he used god's name in vain most of
those would consider it was used as an
interjection not as a source from whom
to beg for wisdom like this country did
for most of our history
since the 60s we really started having
these mass shootings perhaps there was
something in the 60s oh jesus christ
so the 60s are to blame for the mass
shootings he actually he really did say
it he really did say it that that um
oh [ __ ] this is crazy ass [ __ ] crazy ass
[ __ ]
maybe some supreme court decisions that
gave rise to people being taught in
school it's whatever you think feels
good
well it's time to get common sense is
this more jd van stock i don't even know
what what is he saying there the supreme
court decisions do you do whatever you
think feels good you know what sounds
talking about he sounds like
uh herschel walker talking about some
agency where men look at girls who look
at other men who look at girls
who are holding guns i don't know you
know it's like what yeah it just makes
it
what the [ __ ] are you talking about i
mean this is just
let's
continue there's not much less left of
this dribble and then we're going to go
to a video of eric swallow everyone okay
yeah cool yeah everyone's pointing out i
got that link but we're gonna let's
watch the rest of um
goomer tear back
and to look historically about where
people are being murdered in record
rates and don't repeat that like the
democrats
let's do common
save lives i'm out of time studio i
don't think it's my connection by the
way that was cutting him off at the end
i think it was the deep state
yeah he was getting clearly sorry they
were like shut this [ __ ] that was
incredibly difficult to follow and
wow that is i mean
boy anyway glad he won't be in office
anymore right who's louis gohmert again
yeah right
well he was uh he was january 6 though
hopefully we get well he may he he may
still be in our history books won't he
uh recount has this eric swalwell uh
calls out republican hypocrisy
um
during the house gun reform hearing the
quote is they say that laws don't work
but they have no problem crafting laws
to take away women's rights to make
their own health care decisions
that law must work ooh
he looks like he's gonna dig into him
here this isn't very long let's take a
listen to what swallow had to say my
favorite
it's about the family we need to address
the family issues in america but we
don't want to help feed a family we're
going to make it harder for kids to live
on food stamps we don't want to help a
family learn we're going to go after
teachers in america we don't want to
help kids go to college we don't want to
give them jobs we're going to vote
against the infrastructure and jobs bill
and then they say that laws don't work
but they have no problem crafting laws
to take away a woman's right to make her
own health care decision that law must
work
my favorite
it's about the family
so he he attacks him right at their core
right at their
again we've been doing this for weeks
for months um and eric swallow is only
pointing out the obvious here i'm glad
he's doing it inside a public earring
though
that is the most important part that he
get this on record because we need more
of this and we need to continue that
more this just like bet o'rourke
approached the [ __ ] eight dildos that
were standing there at the nra press
conference the nra presser after 19
children were slaughtered trying to
justify why that gun wasn't the problem
why it was the back doors why it was
porn why it was music what we've done
this [ __ ] before in the 90s folks
blame everything but the actual problem
it's infuriating uh i got another clip
that somebody brought what we got
um is this uh eric swalwell no no no no
this is a it's a dumb [ __ ]
oh this is congressman greg
stube
his actual name is stoob oh i'm assuming
i don't even know how you spell it i've
never heard of this guy before but uh
it's s-t-e-u-b-e oh he even posted this
[ __ ]
right
oh this is this has got to be a great
one because florida's 17th district
of course
of course and this is congressman greg
stoob the roof
stood the room
i'm just going to call him stupid from
now on
the rube
um he writes i think this is during the
same
meeting this is the same hearing that
they're all having this is june 2nd
um and he's posting this on his account
i'm not pulling this from some account
goofing on him i'm pulling this from his
account here and we're gonna give great
dumbass credit like we always do
to this tweet it's probably gonna suck
he says everything you need to know
about gun control package democrats
don't even want to let me show what
they're trying to ban
i'm an american
in my own home and i'll do whatever
what i want with my guns mr chairman see
this is more we were talking about this
yesterday
this is more of this uh
this uh i get to do anything i want
white culture type [ __ ] right you know
his name is pronounced stooby
so now i'm just gonna no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way
wait wait wait wait
we thought we thought it was bad that
his [ __ ] name was pronounced stoob
and it took one step further this guy's
name is
how the [ __ ] don't we know about this
guy yet oh boy this sounds made up this
sounds [ __ ] made up i'm not gonna lie
this sounds made up stooby
representative scooby doo doo doo doo
doo
doo doo
can you imagine if he starts talking
like that oh play this i don't know who
this guy is yeah neither do i
i'll look him up let's let's see what
wacky has to say
right here in front of me i have a sig
sauer p226 oh he does sound he does he
does sound like a [ __ ] he definitely
sounds like a scooby
oh you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me all
right let's back it up because i can't i
can't open
right here in front of me i have a sig
sauer p226
comes with a 21 round magazine
look at his dick look how big his dick
is oh my god everybody he is such a huge
dick look look his penis is humongous
why is his gun loaded why is the gun
loaded i don't know
what happened are we not practicing
proper gun safety here guys no what what
is what is he trying to flip out i don't
know
he's awesome he's awesome he even knows
how to use his penis i'm the punisher
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm the punisher
okay let's let's continue with this
manly man who has to show us his manhood
on camera because he's got to make up
for something else this gun would be
banned here's a here's a 12 round
magazine this magazine would be banned
under this current bill it doesn't fit
because this gun was made for a 20 round
21 round magazine oh it's
great so ban it
but what the [ __ ] who gives a franchise
it doesn't [ __ ] so clearly
my [ __ ] piece the thing that i used to
make my dick look big it would be banned
it would be bad i wouldn't even be able
to carry this around and flash in front
of people to show people how big my dick
is
my dick would look small if i didn't
have the ability to have this [ __ ]
gun to show to people can you even
imagine what kind of heartache i would
have if i couldn't walk around trying to
prove to people how big my penis is
i'm a proud boy here i need to show my
[ __ ] to everyone that's a throwback to
yesterday's joke
let's listen this gun would be banned
under this bill good here's a sig sauer
320 yeah he takes a 20 round magazine
takes a 20 round magazine well maybe
here's a 12 magazine that would be
banned it doesn't fit yeah good because
it would be banned
this gun would be banned under this bill
good here's a gun i carry every single
day to protect myself my family my wife
my home this is this is a gun i carry
every day to make my my wiener look big
just i you you know what i bet this guy
i bet this [ __ ] guy almost a hundred
percent if we looked up
what kind of [ __ ] cars he has
registered i almost bet you a million
[ __ ] dollars this guy's got a truck
that's got like a six inch lift stupid
[ __ ] mud tires on it it's it's it's a
quad cab eight foot bed he's never put a
single [ __ ] thing never hauled a
single [ __ ] thing in this truck not a
[ __ ] thing in this truck i almost bet
that this guy has several things that
make up for the size of his [ __ ]
oh yeah
this is a xl sig sauer p365 comes with a
15 round magazine i've got a smaller
seven round magazine which would be less
than what it would be lawful under this
bill if this bill were to come off it
doesn't fit so this gun would be banned
good
gun is not loaded
i'm at my house i can do whatever i want
with my guns here's a point of order is
exactly what the democrats want to do
now let's just take
i'm at my house i can do whatever i want
the person asked the exact same question
why are these [ __ ] guns loaded
like this also to give that he's like
i'm in my house i can do whatever i want
okay when this [ __ ] thing misfires
and you shoot yourself in the dick that
small dick that you have
i'm gonna laugh my ass off when you get
charged thousands of dollars because our
health care system [ __ ] sucks can you
imagine if the mass shooter new baldy
was in a congressional hearing and he
was showing off his guns he was like no
i bought this on a credit card look at
these two guns and you want to ban these
you want look i bought 1700 rounds and
it would be banned it would be banned
under this bill this gun that i got it
would be banned under this bill can you
imagine can you imagine if they were
like hey why do you have a load again
he's like i'm in my house i can do
whatever the hell i want this is mass
shooter type thinking this what what
scooby-doo here is doing scooby-doo
is is projecting mass killer mass gunman
active shooter type type mentality i can
do whatever i want with my guns yeah
don't you understand scooby doo you're
the bad guy with the [ __ ] gun dummy
right scooby [ __ ] dude are you
[ __ ] kidding me the fact that he's
like i carry this gun every day to
protect myself and my family okay
realistically if someone were to see you
with a gun you're already cr it's not
you're not a deterrent to create safety
you're a deterrent to create fear people
who carry guns especially in areas that
are permit-less
create fear just like people want to say
we got to give teachers the guns so you
want to govern and teach under fear we
got to give nurses and cops and patients
to guns so you want to heal with fear
like every point at which
every point at which you enter a gun
into a situation
you know so so this is the first time
i've ever put a gif with this i said
your tweet sucks featuring on today's
tony michaels podcast and i put a gif
retro retro
i can't help it i can't help it scooby
doo here stooby doo here has mass
shooter mentality man
maybe we oh dude we did the uh star wars
parody maybe we should do this
yeah
and it turns out you know that you know
the meme where they reveal the mask and
like who's the villain right it just is
his face it is exposing himself he's
like wait you're the bad guy with the
gun yes
you are the [ __ ] bad guy with the gun
the whole time like if it wasn't for you
meddling kids you know
it's scooby doo it's scooby-doo
scooby-dooby-doo
i wonder if twitter will ask me no
they're not going to they're cool
yeah you put a gif in baby and they're
like hey you're cool with that tweet
they're like nope nope
we're cool with that one
row
oh my god
doobie
scooby is his [ __ ] name stewie
smoking a scooby yeah i i would almost
bet i would almost bet that if you asked
this guy about doobies he would be like
oh no that's the problem right that's
the problem
oh he's like if i can't jerk off with a
[ __ ] nine millimeter in my right hand
go i can see how little my dick is
then i'm not doing it right you know
that's exactly when you said what kind
of car he says here's the thing i
guarantee yes he probably also has a 4x4
with some [ __ ] truck nuts on the back
but oh huge they're dragging those
plastic nuts or dragging the ground
they're just like dragging the ground
but i also think
that he probably i immediately oh he's
driving a [ __ ] 86 camaro like that's
the type of person oh yeah yeah stupid i
bet i bet scooby has his name on the
[ __ ] camaro oh yeah he's got a he's
got a personalized plate that says big
dick on the big big dick yeah big dick
he's like my other dick is a gun
guaranteed he has a bumper sticker that
says something dumb like that
it didn't well
he definitely is a dumb [ __ ] for sure uh
let's see what else do we have trending
today we are 27 minutes into the the
bottom of the hour are you going to have
our clip for this segment today is it
for us on the show are we going to do it
later we're going to do it later but
here i'll play the clip that i shared
with you yeah sure sure did you load it
did you load it up i'm not load it up in
the show and then i'll uh and then i'll
play it from there because it's uh how
how long was it it's just like a minute
wouldn't it we'll give them just a
minute but i well it doesn't have all
the graphics on there yet so i might
just do the teacher one where i read
yeah yeah yeah that's fine that's fine
yes but that's like a quick little
little yeah yeah but put that one in
there and we'll we'll look at that one
um in the meantime while we have our
producer doing producer type things um
we have uh the hashtag biden is a
failure trending um
oh jesus these these guys just can't
quit they think they think inflation all
around the world that oil going up all
around the world is biden's fault um it
is it's biden's fault that's what i've
been told right everything everything
that happens
is biden's fault they can't stop
but to blame i mean it is
it is uh like john points out here uh
buying
biden is a failure at doing crap like
this look at that
that was all biden's fault
lucky there i mean those are all biden
supporters for sure i mean it's biden's
fault because he rigged the election oh
these people break the law and break
into a federal building and you know
cause death
but gabe i thought blue lines matter
this does not look like this in this
picture this is blue lives doesn't
matter this is a difference
they've been here the republicans have
been like hey blue lives
like blue lives don't matter you know so
it's like oh i see you here it's like in
parentheses it's like when you see the
blue flag for like the the black stripes
in the blue line right underneath there
in the corner in like a very very small
one point find it says don't
don't mind tiny print tiny blue lives
don't matter
well it happens all right let's go to
this is a short clip yeah 15 seconds
little little snip little snip what was
that
15 second little snip dean's thinking so
let's let's watch maybe watch the
goblins let's watch teachers are some of
the most stressed underpaid and
under-appreciated workforces out there
they should be teaching
not acting as security guards i mean
does anyone else hear how insane this
sounds i'm sorry but i feel like i'm
taking crazy pills
maybe you should eat some scooby scooby
snacks i don't know do
that's a little 15 second clip uh
reaction that i have during this
whole [ __ ] thing where trump talks
about he brings up three different ideas
of how we can prevent future mass
shootings in schools and
i have a couple clips of of ted cruz and
uh
so yeah it should be a fun one people
seem like they're fun it should be done
today right it should be done today yeah
it should be done today is this a wig no
it's my real hair is you know i just
wear a hat in the morning because i'm
either i either come back from working
out or i wake up and i'm straight yeah
i'm i'm just making that dumbbell
i have to wake him up sometimes and whip
him into shape here you know
i live in the past right i live in the
past west coast like six hours in the
past yeah i mean you know you stay up
all night drinking your streamed water
so yeah you know speaking of which i got
right here and
um south dakota is trending i'm sure
it's because christy gnome is a [ __ ]
bonehead uh is she gonna end up on the
bonehead
list this week or something what is
going on what is she talking about
what's going on i don't know i don't
know south dakota's trending it it's not
clear why
do
lindsay says you're waiting until you
learn about christie gnome taking 1
million from a private donor in exchange
for sending south dakota national guard
to the border
people have concerns about
fascist misusing service members because
they've watched fascist misuse service
members um
looks like adam kensinger tweeted
something here he said this is so over
the top a state guard is not a personal
army
the breathlessness of some of on the
left is why no one takes either side
seriously anymore oh
he's tweeting at bob's south florida
water man
water dean
is he's tweeting at him
um
apparently
bob says florida state guard opens its
doors for the first time in decades
democrats slam desantis plan for the
army now we will be under a regime
and it won't be used like it should
florida has become a satellite state for
north korea
with our own kim jong-un kim jung
desantis apparently is what
dean is saying
water dean is saying florida state
guards opens this door for the first
time in decades
what does that mean
i don't know i didn't i didn't know
anything about this i do know about
desantis and his plan to have his own
little like state army
right
i don't know i don't know he signed a
bill for funding right well i mean he he
definitely wants to make sure he has
protection um when he actually sees from
the union as he sees it um and in
kensington i don't know what the [ __ ]
that's about but um lindsey points out a
good a good point that it's not just uh
ron desantis doing this
it's governors all over the country
wanting to use their militias to not
only protect themselves in their own
states but to go
as a private army for their own
ideological gains in others
um i don't know and then is that why
south dakota is trending i have no idea
here's the thing like every day
something's trending and i'm like i
don't know why it's trending and it
could be for the reason i think and it
also could be for the complete opposite
right it gets hairy when you especially
when you start talking about people like
christy gnome
wait wait go to the video go to that was
17 hours ago what did you say there joe
biden has threatened to take away
children's school lunch money oh my god
these are the same people who want to
defund schools in education take away
school supplies and make sure that kids
who who cannot afford they just don't
even get okay you know what they don't
want they want to feed kids they want to
malnourish kids they don't care about
[ __ ] kids you want to listen to a
horrible take on kids school lunch
you're about to see it i don't even have
to watch it to know it let's listen
president joe biden is using the school
lunch program to push his radical left
wing agenda
he believes that biological boys should
share the same bathrooms and showers
okay so this is all transphobic [ __ ] and
and you're going to see this this month
uh
have you seen the [ __ ] the [ __ ] uh
matt walsh
oh yeah what the hell is a woman type
thing he doesn't he can't he doesn't
know what a woman is so he had to make a
whole movie trying to figure out what a
woman was yeah
is he married
i don't know i would you marry him i
mean can you imagine anyone marrying
that [ __ ] in-cell piece of [ __ ] i
could imagine some women actually
marrying like this one like this one
yeah just like i could imagine someone
marrying ted cruz you know like it
happens
it happens it happens
yeah isn't christy noam also the person
that uh used her political power to get
her daughter
yeah her daughter was a real estate
broker agent and then try to get her a
license right and then she you know
massaged the laws as the governor to
make sure that her daughter
was able to get the license that she
needed
hmm
crazy crazy crazy crazy well she's
spreading she's spreading transphobia
like a wildfire and again we can't look
away we got to know this is the governor
this is the governor of a state as
biological girls
he also thinks that boys should be
allowed to compete on girls sports teams
so he's threatening to use the national
school lunch program to bully states
into falling in line and if we don't
he's going to take food off of our kids
plates
republicans are against
the measures the coven measures to pay
for all kids school lunch they let it
expire yeah
it was actually a thing that could have
been voted on in the
big bird bill yeah the bbb the big bird
bill i mean speaking speaking of covid
she's also the governor
that had the highest
super spreader event two years in a row
her state has the worst numbers the
worst numbers the worst
and she's also the person that gave
trump a miniature model
of the mount rushmore with his face on
it which you can see in some photos when
trump brings people over to his office
in mar-a-lago and he does a dumb [ __ ]
thumbs-up [ __ ] you can see it on the
little table stand that's below on the
bottom
oh my god it's insane
well here we go let's listen to more of
this nonsense
with all the problems that are facing
america today from the border to crime
to inflation and gas you've done nothing
to help about president should be
focusing on solutions for those problems
i have a message for president biden if
you do this if you take food away from
our children literally off their plates
unless we allow boys to compete in girls
sports in south dakota i will
immediately file suit to protect our
kids we've beaten you in court before
and we'll do it again okay so what she's
talking about here is the federal
government's ability to look at states
and say oh by the way
you can't pass those laws or we won't
give you funding for your schools you're
going to have to fund them on your own
right um and this nonsense about the
school lunches that's over
that's over that funding that special
funding she's talking about where it
pays for all skids lunches that's over
she's she is using republicans in action
blaming it on biden and using her
homophobic transphobic [ __ ] bigotry
yeah to justify this nonsense and i hope
she files dude
she's gonna file fun some dumb [ __ ]
lawsuit and spend more money
more more money for her state for south
dakota
so that way she can she can continue to
make [ __ ] tick tocks like this or
whatever this is to complain about how
jordan's doing nothing when it was the
republicans the republicans who refused
to act to make sure that all children in
this in this country which i think
is actually easy to do it's easy to say
all children who go to public schools
get food while they're there and it's
not that's not hard to do republicans
republicans are the party where you
could literally be in a crisis where
let's say that somebody's like oh no i'm
losing blood i need a transfusion right
and they happen to have like vials of
blood or like bags of blood and they're
like huh
nope not gonna help you you could have
you could have children that are
starving that need food that are
malnourished and they could be sitting
at a table and all of the gluttony that
is the food around them is in front of
republicans and their problems i can't
share you really need to do the work for
yourself like these are the people that
could literally have their resources and
do have the resources and funding and
the ability
to give someone who needs help
help however they are unwilling to do so
they're they're unwilling to do so
despite the fact
that they have all the power and the
control and the resources and the
funding to do so whether it's feeding
kids and giving them proper nutrition or
it's making sure that people have proper
health care we're making sure that we
could actually control and make sure
that there's the actual gun safety in
this country the trashiest [ __ ] thing
about that video is that she makes she
makes children's school lunch about
bathrooms these people are [ __ ]
weirdos you are [ __ ] weirdos you keep
talking about [ __ ] bathrooms and
genitalia yeah
and half like it has anything it is
weird lunch
you're [ __ ] weirdos dude it's weird
they're gonna you know they're trying to
pull down pants and look up skirts to
make sure that you are who you are based
on your birth certificate like these are
[ __ ] weird people you know we've said
it before they want to marry your kids
they want to ban your books they want to
get rid of history they want to control
what you say what you think that what
you do follow in line like a real cult
member does don't question just act as i
do
these are the people
that want to control our country these
are the people that want to be
in the white house control the house
control the senate
this is the poison that is ruining the
well well and
i but you know maybe they've learned
their lesson gabe maybe they have no no
no no no no no
no
do you trust susan collins on this hell
no
that
dude wait wait that wasn't as good a
transition yeah yeah okay speaking
speaking of people
speaking of people
who
think that they've other people and
other things have learned their lessons
susan collins thinks guns
have learned their lesson she says
we may we are making rapid progress
towards a common sense package that
could garner support from both
republicans and democrats
show she is she thinks they've learned
their lesson here
is what she thinks
um i don't know i don't know this seems
do you trust her i don't [ __ ] no i
would never trust her i wouldn't trust
her if my life depended on it and it
does honestly it does depend on it but i
wouldn't trust her she is someone who
has again and again you know we saw what
happened roe v wade she was like they
wouldn't they wouldn't cross their
fingers and lie to me they told me that
it was it was law it was law of the land
they weren't going to overturn roe v
wade
they wouldn't they wouldn't try to upend
it and take get rid of it right and
everyone's like yeah they will most
definitely do that look no they look
like they're in
donald trump told her that he didn't do
anything wrong and brett kavanaugh told
her that he was not a rapist and they've
learned their lesson so
you know we have to believe susan
collins we have to trust her
right we have to we must trust her with
i don't i i can't even figure out how
mane
isn't
already in the situation where they're
trying
their damnedest
to recall her what do you know what the
recall laws are in in maine i'm not sure
i know they have i know they have ranked
choice i know they have ranked choice
voting
um which is kind of unique in this
country there's there's few a few places
that have it you got me a link here is
there a video uh caitlyn was saying that
there is a video of lauren bobert doing
a soldier prayer video so i figured i
would get that a what a what a soldier
prayer video
lauren bobert
yeah i know who that is yeah yeah yeah
christian there's there's scooby and
then they're stupid yeah yeah right well
they're all stupid but right right right
and just not maybe the scooby type of
stoop well they might be the stupid type
of
stupid i don't know we need to we need
to remake the song maybe we should get
the misty modell on the um
on the on the horn and see if we can get
her to help us with the uh oh yeah a
scooby-doo a scooby-doo remake or
something
a
little
ditty she's great at parodies um this
this tweet comes from ron this video
says lauren bobert and representative
doug lamborn
christian soldiers what what
oh and christian will i see yeah lord
strengthen them in the name of the blood
in the name of the
it is hard it is hard to read what she
even says lord strengthen them in the
name of the blood of jesus
and may this state be turned red with
the blood of jesus and politic what what
what
is that really is there's no way that's
what she says dude okay before we play
the video when someone that line right
there the state be turned red with the
blood of jesus that line reminds me when
somebody says i want the the streets to
be uh
to be uh full of the blood of whoever
this person that they're trying to go
against right like i want them to be
incredibly blood like they hate jesus
like she's saying she hates jesus here
i
is that what you're saying it's like she
hates and but she says and politically
yeah because she realized what she said
it sounds like may the state turn red
with the blood of jesus pew pew pew pew
pew bang bang bang bang bp
and then she's like oh and politically
and i'm gonna end that there is a long
pause ellipses and politically right
well let's and and politically
that might be it might be a question
mark let's find out let's find out doug
so much i thank you for his 15 years he
so faithfully served you god i just
thank you for the heart that he has and
and really that that vision of prayer
has been a part of doug and jeanne's
life for the joy of being a part of it
personally but also seeing how it has
pressed him into making decisions that
he's been criticized and maligned for
but he's done the right thing he's done
the biblical thing he's followed he's
not blessed
but i want to just thank you so much for
uh these men and women
i think we're going to be surprised here
i don't think it's actually her
do you do you think it's her that's
saying this or he's going to say this
i think i think it's her that says it i
don't know i haven't let's i'm
they're running yeah office i know most
of them and their godly men and women
god we can bless them and strengthen
them in their campaigns father god would
you pour out your spirit upon them but
they have wisdom and discernment beyond
their abilities i pray for supernatural
strategies
okay so here's your natural strategy
i don't know that's like that's like
racial confusion remember yesterday kurt
cameron racial confusion now she is
praying here she's saying something on
her own as this guy's talking i don't
know if she's like saying the same thing
he's saying or what i don't know what
the hell is going on here this is you
know
i i i grew up in the catholic church so
did you there's a lot of old religious
dogma in catholic church there's none of
this really there's none of this
nonsense in the catholic dogma you know
where they they put their hands on
people and pray over them then i do
exorcisms and [ __ ] some other type weird
ass [ __ ] the only thing i'm finding for
supernatural strategies is uh
is
supernatural strategies for making a
rock and roll group
well you know that actually sounds like
a pretty good 80s rock band i'm not i'm
just saying supernatural supernatural
strategies like they probably there was
probably a rock band in the 1980s i
don't know i don't know they were weird
to come to these men and women and
father for lauren i just thank you for
her family and thank you for her i thank
you for the holiness and in the case of
doug
lord i pray for boldness
does anyone have something for doug
right no okay uh anyway if you write
something down for doug who the [ __ ] is
who the [ __ ] is doug
oh my god what the [ __ ] is he's like my
name is dan oh [ __ ] sorry dan
dan doug who gives a [ __ ] damn dog who
gives a [ __ ] let's
know that they're finish when you
strengthen them in the name of the blood
of jesus and may
this state
be turned red
whoa
did you hear the crowd yeah
yeah listen either he's waiting to say
politically like he's he's forgotten it
for a moment or he's waiting
like a like an actual showman in this
sense to wait for the reaction and then
deliver politically right right he was
like wait i'm gonna turn right
oh yeah bring it in bring it in because
turn red you could say maybe they're
gonna vote red right like they're gonna
vote republican here and that's why
they're like yeah and then he's like
with the blood of jesus you know he does
like the alex jones thing oh the demons
come out politically politically
politically and back to the sermon and
right and back to the sermon let's
listen
[Applause]
look at that hand whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what is it
we've seen it we've seen it before we've
seen it before she did it at the uh
pre-born
uh women babies matter
right
now i mean she really needs to get her
fingers straightened up here yeah like
hitler would be very disappointed he
probably wouldn't put up with this kind
of uh hand salute here hitler hitler
would really want her fingers to be out
straight
notch no
yeah yeah she's like i'm giving a high
five to jesus it's like no you're not no
you're not right no let's back it up and
let's listen to this blood red thing
let's listen to this one more time
family and thank you for her and thank
you for her boldness and in the case of
doug
lord i pray for both cases
they know that they're
you strengthen them in the name of the
blood of jesus and make
this day
be turned red
so i think he means republican i mean
she's like yeah baby yeah baby she got
up there real quick throw that nazi hand
up there so i think it is i think yeah
uh caitlin's right poor doug
you're just like and in the case of doug
pause [ __ ] up
i don't i don't know seriously did
anyone write anything from doug did doug
write something for doug right do we
know what do we know is doug actually
does is this doug is this this is this
guy is this guy doug can anyone verify
he's like no my name's carl yeah
but i think at that moment when he was
like i will turn this state red i think
he's talking
red like the republican red now it
didn't help he said then the blood of
jesus
right blood of jesus
and politically speaking
right that's what he's i don't know it's
uh
oh son of a [ __ ]
these [ __ ] christians are [ __ ]
weirdos let me ask you gabe because i
want to get your take on this speaking
of weird speaking of weirdest oh yeah i
always got weird takes uh well no not
well you are a weirdo
but no i'm talking about other hollywood
elite weirdos not your holly not not you
the hollywood elite weirdo the other
hollywood elite weirdos
did you know that there was a trial
going on with johnny depp neighborhood
did you know that
i was aware of that oh okay you know
this is kind of flown by it it happened
so fast
no one was talking about it it was like
it didn't happen for weeks right
it's almost like it's got more coverage
and importance
in society than like i don't know the
january 6th hearings right
right
so tell me your take on it we might as
well now that it's over we might as well
get your take on what this is this is my
take
those two people
are toxic as [ __ ]
they are not someone they're not a pair
that should be together
oh they deserve each other baby i think
that's what the judge should have done
is said look
you you are going to pay 15 million
dollars of damage to her
you're going to pay 15 million damage to
him and you two are sentenced to a life
with each other like we want to make
sure that no one else has to put up with
your [ __ ] garbage okay this is this
is what i will say she cr she wrote her
op-ed you know that was done and that's
where the 15 million comes from right it
was a defamation lawsuit and right he
had he owes what you're what you're
saying is because we really haven't done
a lot of commentary other than there are
a bunch of dumb [ __ ] on the show right
so she wrote an op-ed about him right
which caused him to lose work right and
that's his claim in this case yeah that
because she wrote these lies about him
and defamed him right he lost he lost
some work especially with disney being
the main
the main with the i think pirates was
the main pirates was the was the main
kind of cash cow well that that was the
fame or that was the film excuse me
right that got uh cancelled because of
the defendant right
but also
but also on the most recent harry potter
film
as well but these were films that they
like waited they're like
and then these things came out in terms
of like the backlash right and then you
find out like oh actually she used this
as a mean suit you know uh defend you
know to
to speak out maliciously against him
right and then you also like the reason
the big issue that i have here is like
yeah they're both toxic or whatever and
you know they do whatever [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but at the end of the day you also have
amber heard who is abusive and a liar
and it goes against the metoo movement
so now
you have women that are like oh
[ __ ] um
are are people gonna believe me because
of people like this
and they were very few i i you know it's
when people are like oh all you know
yeah nick adams
yesterday that that [ __ ] that piece
trump ass sucking cuck is someone who
wait wait wait wait do we have a new
category now [ __ ] trump ass
yeah
so i i look at i look at this situation
and
people like him on the right were like
he did it for us he defended man he did
it he did it because all women are liars
like that's the narrative they've taken
which is unfortunate to see the right
co-op that like he was you know he was
proven
to be
a victim in that sense
and as a result all women who come
forward about men are now liars
and that's what right-wing men are doing
right now which is sad and unfortunate
and that's the actual take i have which
is through this whole thing that we've
we've seen on television we've seen
these reactions and we've seen these
takes like at the end of the day
like
that is what people are that is what men
are pulling out of it a white in-cell
insecure
so you've got her right she you know she
writes this thing she makes it up
whatever you know to whatever extent
now you have women who are like well
[ __ ] now this case was just
johnny jeff just won this case
because it was shown to say that she was
actually malicious but they both kind of
won here he got 15. yeah yeah i mean
that's something yeah she gets yeah
because of what her
his lawyer i think right right well
here's here's the thing here's the thing
and a lot of people think like this is
gonna break her apart and she's gonna be
broke amber hurd is actually gonna get
roles from this like they're gonna put
her in movies just to have her name on
the marquee because of the craziness
that has ensued i had no [ __ ] clue
who amber heard was you'd have to point
her out to me in a movie well i knew
what johnny depp was right she wasn't in
a lot of movies she is now going to be
and 15 million dollars in the world of
johnny depp is not that much money it
really isn't he was trying to prove a
point here and i guess he proved it now
we had to [ __ ] bear through it and by
us i mean
the [ __ ] pop culture had to bear
through this nonsense when there's so
many other things that we could have
been paying attention to and i really
think that that is the story here that
americans are obsessed with tom brady
retiring and then not retiring retiring
and johnny depp and amber heard being a
bunch of [ __ ] boxes yeah like this is
this is not the kind of stuff that we
need to put a lot of stock in it's fun
it's fun to talk about it's fun to
create funny memes and funny things and
it's it that's great and all
but we really need to focus on and put
our effort into things that actually
matter and johnny depp is not going to
extend his hand to try to help stop 19
children and yuvaldi to be slaughtered
and the people in the hospital to be
slaughtered and the people in the
grocery store to be slaughtered if
that's not going to fix the actual real
[ __ ] problems it's not going to fix
the the ability for women to regain
their rights that they have been
afforded for [ __ ] decades with the
autonomy of their [ __ ] bodies it's
not going to
fix the problem where republicans are
coming after the right for people to
marry who the [ __ ] they want to marry to
be who they want to be it is not going
to stop
and
that trial and
again in pop culture it's fun yeah but
it's the reality tv america
that is not paying attention to what the
reality actually is and the reality
actually is that johnny depp and amber
heard are two [ __ ] boxes they kind of
deserve each other as far as you know
their toxic relationship like you said
um now rather they deserve money or not
i guess the judge and the jury has
afforded them that that that money
but
they don't deserve a lot of our
attention other than to say
hey
that's not the thing that you should be
so concerned with right like it's fun
but that's not the thing you should be
concerned with there's so many other
things
so many other [ __ ] things that you
could be worried about right now like i
don't know there was a shooting in a
hospital the place that you you think
you would be safe because you were
injured and you're getting proper care
and treatment despite the fact that it
costs a [ __ ] ton of money you now have
to worry you're like oh [ __ ] i just paid
all this money or i will pay all this
money because i was injured up and i
just got shot like
what the [ __ ] well gabe what better
place to get shot than a hospital come
on man i mean you know really honestly
maybe we should encourage more hospital
shootings i mean out loud i'm sure some
republicans is going to is going to make
that
is going yeah it's going to make the
argument that the response time and
efficiency of getting someone from
victim or patient into a room
you know
maybe crews won't want to ban doors in
hospitals because the hospital is the
place to get shot right they're like
guys if you want to get shot go to a
hospital just hang out the hospital holy
[ __ ] that's the overrun the hospital it
wasn't already busy enough it wasn't
that people couldn't be seen for hours
so you know what pile on in
and then we'll get a shooter in there
and then everyone will be seen
i mean we're making this as a joke but
this is in all seriousness by the end of
the day there's probably going to be an
actual politician making the argument
somewhere that hey you know this is a
tragedy down in tulsa that five people
were killed but what better place to get
shot than a hospital it's gonna be a
better place like with that being said
it's just gonna be that curb your
enthusiasm joke where they're like
listen uh yeah it is unfortunate but
with that being said i mean what a
better what what a better place to get
shot you know
it's true because the only thing that
stops a bad guy with a gun is a patient
with a gun really honestly i mean if you
think about it if you think about it
it's it's a or a gurney with a gun maybe
that's what they should do is just start
in installing just like tourists
automatic weapons right with the buttons
yeah no go for it you know like that you
know you push your your morphine button
but they should have a
you know a trigger button on the bed
it's like some random action right right
you got a joystick yeah you can slow
down you know i mean i mean i don't know
republicans said it was uh those violent
games so it makes sense you know you're
in you're in your gurney and you're in
your bed and you've got your controls to
go up down and forward and back and
you're like and i press the red button
put the 50 cal on it put that down
let's get another round
right really get really get some damage
going on
when the mass shooters come in to kill
the cancer patients are you [ __ ] this
is absolutely bonkers batshit crazy
uh pay attention america pay the [ __ ]
attention i mean yeah have your fun with
your johnny depp amber heard means but
pay the [ __ ] attention and you can do
that one way to do it is every single
weekday monday through friday two hours
every single week gabe yesterday
we had a great interview you can watch
our show right here every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the minuses facebook
page but yesterday gabe we had an
interview um with a marine veteran who
knows a lot about gun safety it ended up
being a really good interview it ended
up being almost an hour i plan on
talking to matt for about 20 minutes but
um the conversation just kind of went on
and on and on with him yeah and so it's
a great it's a great one we're gonna put
that on the youtube channel today i
actually think um we might send a clip
to midas touch um of that interview some
of the highlights of that and send it to
my touch so they can put it on their
channel for more people to see so go
check that out over on their youtube
channel don't forget to subscribe to
their youtube channel as well as ours if
you haven't done that already um
but check that out we'll be we'll be
releasing that interview in and of
itself today i hope we can get that out
and so you guys can go re-watch that
because and spread that interview around
um matt's video went viral the other day
when he was talking about gun control
and military and how the military
controls guns so go watch that interview
it's super super important and i promise
you we had no idea that the tulsa
hospital shooting was going to happen
but we talk about stuff in that
interview that absolutely applies to
what happened yesterday in tulsa so go
check that out again don't forget every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central right here on
youtube twitter twitch subscribe to the
youtube channel also we simulcast to the
minus touch facebook page and this
afternoon gabe we will put out our
bonehead of the week poll so go to
tonymichael's pod follow us on twitter
you will be able to vote for bone net of
the week you decide who the bone of the
week is we break it down tomorrow
because tomorrow's friday gabe
tomorrow's friday and on friday every
every friday in the second hour we break
down your vote a bone end of the week
so until tomorrow surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking